foreign
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
when uh Nicholas Cage says it in uh what
do you call it uh that movie uh Bad
Lieutenant to the breakouts down baby
dude that made me laugh so hard when he
does that CNC and also so [ __ ] dope
too the way he said it so this [ __ ] in
sicincy it's all the circle that meets
in the middle there uh or at the top
rather
um crystalia.com go get your tickets I
will be in let's see Boston uh November
I believe 12th the first uh show is sold
out the second show is added at the Wang
and it's selling out go get your tickets
in Boston I will be there very soon
um I will also be in Lakeland Florida I
will also be in
um Jacksonville Florida and
um I've got some other shows too in
um Brea California I have announced that
I will be there for New Year's Eve uh
doing like four shows over there five
maybe San Diego added a show Portland
getting up there uh Seattle Washington
is uh I record this a little bit in
advance it may be sold out at this point
but it may be a few seats left so go to
chrysler.com
San Antonio Texas I never mentioned that
one uh chrisley.com that's February 3rd
San Antonio Texas Sugarland Texas
everyone's say I get a lot of hit up hey
when are you coming to Houston
I'm going to Sugarland it's 20 minutes
outside of Houston go there I'm
traveling the whole way you travel 20
minutes February 4th New Orleans uh
February 5th Providence Rhode Island
February 17th New York New York Beacon
we added another show February 18th and
then Chicago Illinois February 25th and
then I'll do the rest later
um further episodes but also
chrisley.com oh I think I added Austin
by this time don't tell anybody I had I
added Austin
um and I believe I added some Kansas
ones and some Ohio ones go check
chrisley.com I don't know if I did it
yet but let's just hear this dude
what sounds better than that baby
drinking but drinking nice you know it's
as my son it's sparkling water AKA what
my son would call it spicy water so cute
um oh by the way also if you've seen me
on the road uh the guy who I bring to
open for me sometimes a hilarious comic
uh Mike La Noche will be at the Brea
Improv November 7th 17th so go check him
out uh if you're in Brea and then come
and see me in New Year's Eve for Brea uh
but whatever you know what I mean this
is episode 283 and we are firing on all
syllables already uh
you know dude
it is what it is right
it's a beautiful day the the day is
beautiful I was talking to my brother
earlier and uh the nice coldness is
coming through in uh in LA and I don't
know if that's
um
you know
the nice coldness is coming through and
my brother said he couldn't wait for it
and then he said
it happened and couldn't wait for it and
then as soon as it happened he woke up
and he was sad about it and ain't that
just like how life goes you wait for
something and it's not as good as what
you thought it would be but uh it's all
good it should be nice and cold even
though uh uh Halloween is over
I'm recording this now like a few days
after uh Halloween and Kristen just goes
like this you know what that means and I
say huh and she says let's decorate for
Christmas and I was like you mean the
rest
because there's already two trees up
and then she made me put a tree
downstairs from upstairs
we got three stories no biggie it was in
the middle
she goes can you bring it downstairs in
the entryway the first floor is really
just an entryway
I mean I'm you know what I mean I'm not
trying to be big baller here I got three
stories one of them is really only where
you walk in and there's Andrew way all
good
but she goes like this hey
hey can you take the tree from the
middle floor and bring it to the bottom
and I go like this why'd you decorate it
from the middle in the middle then she's
like I'm not gonna be near the garage
decorating the tree I want to be nice
about it so I'm like okay cool yeah true
you want to be nice about it I get it
be nice about it in the middle I get it
as nice as a fireplace you decorate the
tree and yeah of course it's [ __ ]
October 15th but still you want to be
nice about it
so you're being nice about it and you're
doing it near the fire you listen to
Christmas music I'm not in the house
because I don't want to listen Christmas
music yet and it's not because it's only
Christmas music
you know your boy he loves Christmas
music but you know what he loves it
closer to Christmas and I would listen
to it in May but here's the deal I don't
want to ruin the specialness of
Christmas I want Christmas to be as
special as it can possibly be and so for
me decorate make the music happen around
November 15th and take it down first
week of January you want to go January
8th that's okay that's when Christmas is
special that's almost two whole months
you get you get two months of Christmas
from November 15th we will go what do
you want to do this is if my wife worked
in behind the camera in the studio were
you want November what do you want can
we go lower you want we want to get
decorate you want to decorating okay
we'll go November can we go we can go
November 8th we'll go November 8th
we'll go November 8th and we will push
it till what do you want darling you
want it up till January
20th we will start November 8th and all
the way to January 20th Christmas There
You Go Darling
you can get it for thousands of dollars
when you go to Target
thousands of dollars when you go to
little Boutique shops
two trees two we give you two trees what
do we want you want three trees we'll
give you three trees and that'll cost
you that'll cost you two what do you
want it you want before Halloween
we'll do it uh we'll do it October 11th
Christmas starts October 11th and it
ends February
29th and if you know anything about that
that's a leap day and it doesn't happen
here for us so really what's happened is
Chris was never over
it doesn't start it doesn't begin it is
always on my wife's mind you get
Christmas
all the time
um so
so yeah so uh we she goes guess what she
says guess what and I said what she says
time to decorate for Christmas so I
brought the tree downstairs and then
guess what
she [ __ ] after that wanted the tree
to go not only to the mid-level
she wants it on the third level
so I brought it down and now gotta bring
it
chew up
all right
hey
is this [ __ ] you know Donkey Kong
like just decide where you want it and
but she's like my mom because she'll be
like then my mom would always come she's
not like my mom in this way but in a
little bit she is but like my mom and I
love her she's my angel but my mom
um would be like can you move a couch
and then I'll be like no she'd be like
can you move a couch with Matt I'm like
all right cool we do it and then she go
she's like this she goes like this
literally like this this is the move
right here I'm gonna put my thing
because this is what she does
foreign
so now I gotta bring the tree up trying
to [ __ ]
you know I like to dilly dally that's me
dude just Dilly Dalian
she says bring the water cases up I go
yeah but I'm a Dilly dallyer
she says yeah you know your one thing is
washing the dishes
the sink's full and they say yeah but
I'm a deli dallyer
I got some Dilly dallying to do
I'm the Dilly dallying stallion
Dylan aliens darling
um
yeah dude I don't I don't uh I like the
dilly dally dude
which is why I haven't made my
colonoscopy appointment yet yes dude
did it make it yet
gotta do it my buddy told me they put a
[ __ ] dude I was talking to my friend
David Sullivan and he was like man they
put you out for 20 minutes it's
incredible they just put you up for 20
minutes I was like dude I would choose
not to and he was like are you kidding
me
I was like hell yeah dude put me in the
Twilight thing you know sometimes they
just put you in a little bit of a
Twilight sleep it's not you're not
really sleeping you're kind of up but
you're like kind of like looking around
and you're like
and he was like man they put a metal rod
up your what what David Sullivan said
was they put a metal rod up your penis
and I was like what doctor did you go to
you I said you mean anus and he said
what yeah or yeah your anus and I was
like oh we gotta stop right there dude
because I don't know if you made a
mistake or if you thought while you're
under they put a metal rod under your
penis to check for [ __ ] colon cancer
who did you go to Dr giggles
so
um I'm gonna do that and I'm a Dilly
Dahlia and my [ __ ] you know I called
my doctor and he was like well you don't
have to do it until 10 years before the
person in your family your the person in
your family first got it so my grandma's
54 I'm 42 so he's like you're a little
on the earlier side but why don't you
you know you can do it if you want to so
I'm like all right let's do it dude
42 years old getting gonna get my anus
checked
um
yeah so we're getting ready for
Christmas and I'm gonna get my anus
checked and you know always [ __ ] just
hear those sleigh bells Ringling
jingling to metal rod Manus and um
uh so I'm doing that and then uh and you
know I I forget because since Christmas
is starting in my household
um
you know I gotta [ __ ] uh we gotta do
that and and and Thanksgiving I guess is
just out the window
I don't know I guess Thanksgiving is
just out the window
uh you know I think we're gonna maybe be
in town for Thanksgiving but I guess
it's just out the window
but what we are going to do
um is uh talk about Halloween right now
because I went on Halloween with my son
uh and my wife and my uh brother Matt
Uncle Matt for Calvin and uh my dad and
my mom and we walked around this one
block where they shut it down and my son
was a purple people eater
one eye one horn purple people eater and
uh and it was great because it was the
first real Halloween that my son was
kind of a uh
uh like a kid and not just like a
you know I don't want to say a blah but
when the kids are like one they're like
now they don't know anything they just
maybe make eye contact and [ __ ] but he
was like walking around he walked up to
people's doors one time he did it
completely by himself it was just really
[ __ ] cute and he was a purple people
eater and Kristen made the costume and
She's Crafty and she's my angel but
she's crafty dude and she uh she put it
together and that's just great man she
put it together and Calvin was happy and
he was so sweaty in his outfit but he
didn't want to take it off he wouldn't
take it off and I was a vampire and it's
just this block that uh that they shut
down and it was [ __ ] awesome man and
then and then I um
and then I uh I did uh this big alien
came came up to me and he was like Chris
Leah and you know I was getting
recognized every now and then even
though I I was dressed I was I was a
vampire I look more like Chrisley than
Chris Lee because I was now I was in my
full form a real vampire I actually look
like a vampire we put the blood down
coming down from my mouth like how I did
in the [ __ ] in our La in our old
podcast in the [ __ ] the golden hour
it's called now that we do over at uh uh
what used to be the king of the state of
the wing and uh and dude um yeah we uh
this big alien said hey what's up Chris
and I was like oh hey and he says it's
me and I couldn't see him and he pulled
back his alien costume and it was like a
screen and he smashed his face and he
said it's Mario and I was like who
and he says Mario Lopez and I was like
oh [ __ ] what's up you're here and he's
like yeah we [ __ ] live here and so uh
you know it was a star-studded event
whatever okay
it's a star threat event
it was me Mario Lopez and then
Frankenstein was there star starter
event I don't know if it was a real one
or not
um but yeah dude Halloween was beautiful
my dad and my mom had a great time my
mom was taking pictures of Calvin she
likes to take really close-up pictures
of Calvin it's crazy she likes to take
really really close-up pictures of
Calvin like up his face and it's so cute
but he doesn't say still and she always
gets blurry pictures and that's all good
dude that's something that would have
made me mad [ __ ] five years ago but
it doesn't now because I'm a changed man
you know I see her taking the pictures
I'm like my just [ __ ] zoom out of it
you can just cut it you can just edit it
towards closer it was a man five years
ago but now I'm a transmit
thank you
know it would have made me mad five
years ago and I'm looking at it I'm
getting heated now but also I simmer it
because I'm a changed man
uh
um
and then Calvin didn't say [ __ ] the
whole Halloween he was just walking
doing a job like focused and then he got
in the car wouldn't stop saying uh
my we got so much candy got so much
candy it was just really cute man really
[ __ ] cute
and then today after Halloween one of
the days after is one of the days after
Halloween and he was like let's look at
my candy and he pulled it up and he was
like should I eat this one and I let him
eat it and it was so cute dude he ate it
and he was like should I have enough
what what should I have a next should I
have another one because I was like
Calvin you should only eat one piece of
candy but um look I let him have a
smorgasbord candy Halloween night he ate
a lot I'm not like one of those parents
that's gonna be like okay enough but he
had a lot and then the next day I was
like let's just have one and he was like
what should I eat next and he pulled out
Skittles and I'm like you're gonna
[ __ ] new first of all you're not
gonna like that second we're gonna choke
on it you don't know what it is so I
pulled out this bar this chocolate bar
that had coconut in it and I'm like I
like that one and I was like Calvin
we'll give you a half of this okay
why don't we give you this is really
cute I was like I'll give you half of
one is that cool and we'll split it and
he said okay so I purposely split it to
where one side was a little bigger and I
said which one do you want and he picked
the big one so cute dude he picked the
big one he goes um you look at the ball
Adam boy goes this one pick the big one
thought he pulling over on me dude it
was so cute I was proud dude he took the
big piece and they put it in the mouth
and we realize he doesn't like coconut
so it's all good
it's all good he spit it out I picked it
up put it in my mouth I ate it I'm a
changed man would I ever take out
regurgitated food from someone's mouth
and eat it no but now my son made me a
bird
[Music]
I'll eat his food straight from his
mouth and give a [ __ ] dude I'm gangster
when it comes to that [ __ ] dude I'm
[ __ ] gangster when my son wants to
give me food that was ABC already been
chewed
that's why I [ __ ] your [ __ ] I'm
gangster dude
um I'm cool with the ABC food
um so uh yeah
that's what I remember Sumatra which
said that in New Jersey you want some
ABC gum
I said what you want some ABC gum it's
good I said sure she said I already been
two here you go I go Sumatra
Sumatra
Sumatra sounds like a golf coffee blend
is it great she's coffee yeah it's
racist she was black so
um all good but that was her name and
she was Brown
skin
you know I suppose I don't remember I
remember one time Sumatra goes like this
dude dude one time Sumatra she I'm
[ __ ] I love you guys thank you for
letting me talk about my life and I was
in school and the [ __ ] teacher Mrs
Esposito was like does anybody know the
answer and I go I say the answer under
my breath so much it was right here
behind me just like this and she goes
raises her hand and says it and then and
then I said I said that and she said
Yoshi you should have raised your hand
don't sleep
and she took it and I forgot that dude
Sumatra what's her last name I would
love to [ __ ] see her now dude there's
a bunch of people you ever think about
your [ __ ] old classmates dude Ronnie
and [ __ ] uh Rosemary Sumatra Mark
um Jenny just people that I don't you
know Matt I keep in touch with Matt
matravenin I keep in touch with a lot of
people from like Elementary School not a
lot no but some right I haven't talked
to Mike levecchio in Forever
um [ __ ] they're like 42 now that's crazy
they probably be getting colonoscopy
soon too but
um let's see Danny Vick where's he now
Omar Pitts the [ __ ] is he I talked to
Omar Holt sometimes
um yeah just giving you a brief on that
man Michael Byrne talked to him for a
bit on Facebook until I got off Facebook
[ __ ] I should probably talk to Michael
Byrne like you know these guys
um yeah
Corey bober dude how's he you ever think
about that man you ever think about how
Corey Wilbur might be
who are the people in your uh childhood
who else man Justin McKinnon dude
loved Freddy Krueger with Chris Siegel
they were best friends they loved horror
movies I [ __ ] was scared of Freddy
Krueger you know about that [ __ ]
um who else dude [ __ ] what dear quadir
dude
Rasheed
[ __ ] man no Asians just zero Asians in
New Jersey you know I moved to La Canada
that changed
that changed dude it's for real went to
school with six Daniel Kim's no joke
look at my yearbook dude you know Kim
then I came there
that's one page dude they came they came
there with them they came Paul Kim that
was another one too
damn
then it was um
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] you know
uh I literally saw a Daniel Kim trick or
treating with my signs like it's been a
long time I was like oh hey what's up
and my mom said oh who's that and I said
I think his name was Daniel Kim but most
of that's just a safe bet racist
but not though if you look at the
numbers
um
yeah dude but we have a good time man so
Halloween was a [ __ ] went off like
gangbusters and uh and it was great dude
uh we had a good time
I love being a deck can't wait till next
year I wonder why my son will want to be
next year I didn't want to be a vampire
but my son wanted me to be to be a
vampire unless I wanted my my wife to be
um a uh a witch and my and my brother
showed up as I said as an American
Cowboy he said no as the American Cowboy
and he did that for Calvin and that's
very sweet and I love it
you know I'm a family man dude what can
I say I'm a [ __ ] family man I went to
the [ __ ] grocery store today because
my wife said can you pick up a few
things what's going on me
hey me what's going on
even the precogs wouldn't have known
about this
even that one character in House of
dragons wouldn't be able to predict this
what's going on me
you picking [ __ ] up
you picking up two Tomatoes you pick it
up two avocados
you're picking up four corn on the cobs
even though she asked for two corn on
the cobs because there was a pack sold
with four corn on the cobs and couldn't
find the single corn on the cops
you picked up some miso dressing even
though she just asked for me so
what's miso if not dressing apparently
it's different she's gonna make chicken
bowls whatever put the miso dressing on
it I'm sure it's fun don't make me feel
insecure when I get home she didn't it's
more my thing
she didn't it's more my thing
what's going on me
you picking up it's a tahini dressing
dude
hey me nice to meet you this is me from
a while ago hi me from the future what
are you doing with taking the dressing
well I'm just picking it up for my wife
get the [ __ ] out of here in a dope car
me hopping in the [ __ ] four-door okay
you'll see me
Yeah man so I picked it all up got I
said man I'll do this for you but I
gotta tell you
I'm gonna [ __ ] it up and she said nah
you're not and I go
the faith
the faith
the faith of who I could possibly be
the faith of who I believe too
resides inside of the center of me
I believe it too
the faith I have in
me getting to that guy today
not so good
maybe you have that faith
could I possibly be my grown self
today could I possibly pick up
the Miso today
I got there I asked the guy where the
[ __ ]
what
what's queso Fresca
what is it dude I said what is it is
that what it was Babe queso Fresca
Fresco what okay so Fresco it's male
it's got a dick dude so I [ __ ] uh I I
said what's queso fresco because I can't
find it baby yes I looked at the cheese
I looked at the [ __ ] I don't even
know what the dairy you know so I
finally asked the guy where's the queso
fresco and well I asked her she said
it's in this is the most white [ __ ] I
don't even know if it's true it's in the
Mexican freezer of the [ __ ]
of the of the grocery store
and I'm like they divided based off of
like what isn't there just freezer she
goes ask an attendant or whatever the
[ __ ] they call a grocer
and uh and ask
ask them where the queso fresco is
now look I don't know what it is
so I asked and I look for a little bit
I'm starting I get pissed I look I asked
the I go as far as I go do you
understand
I I go as far as you know how people you
know how far I go one mile right you
know people go the extra mile
I don't do that I go one mile when
people say hey how many miles do you go
to get the job done I'm already right
there like this
I go one mile
those [ __ ] [ __ ] I will look 500
miles and I will walk 500 more dude me I
will walk one mile and I won't walk
another mile
I walk only one mile and not one step
more than Linda Linden
um so yeah so I you know that here's
what the extra mile is on that
expedition
I I look for the queso fresco Fresco
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
I asked the grocer the grocer points to
where it is he walks me over Grocer's
always so [ __ ] nice right
grow all Grocers I've ever been to and
talked with they will like literally
walk here hey come here let me show you
did I had a grocery once walk out of
ShopRite and walk into another grocery
store or grocery store come here it's
over here we don't have it but here come
here hop in here kick put the seatbelt
on
here get out they have it here you go
there it is Greek yogurt we don't have
it there you go I'll walk back take the
car home
horses are nice as [ __ ] dude
so I'm like all I got to do I know is
ask where queso fresco what is it what
is it called crazy scope Fresco is
I'm like Foghorn Leghorn over here okay
okay uh Fresco Fresco and uh she'll say
where's the queso fresco and he goes
like this
and I'm like
see here's the thing too when you ask a
grocery store person what do you call
them Grocers
what what do you where's the first of
all I never know
who's the actual real person to ask for
this [ __ ] because you got two people you
got the people who ring you up and the
people who work in the back
and sometimes those people who work in
the back come up and box stuff and I'm
like I guess I'll ask them if they box
if they unbox this but I don't know is
that a real person but here's the
[ __ ] twist this is like the M Night
Shyamalan movie of it all the people who
work the checkout they're also the
people who work in the back so everybody
who's a girl says the same [ __ ] job
didn't know that till recently
I mean yeah work in the line might be
your specialty but it's all the same
because they wear different [ __ ]
sometimes right they have the apron on
if they're dealing with meats or fish or
yams or whatever the [ __ ] or queso
fresco so like we're the case of Fresco
and I ask him near the dairy [ __ ] so I'm
like he'll probably just be like right
here if not he'll walk me over to the
thing so he goes like this ah so I'm
like this guy doesn't even know he's
standing next to the dairy shits
so he goes like it should be here um
here look here come here and he walks
over and I'm walking with him and he
goes like this here's where all the
cheese is and I go
not what I uh in my head I'm like not
what I asked
so I say
that's where that mile stops I say okay
I don't go the extra mile because I
asked the grocer where the [ __ ] was he
walked and he pointed and he said over
here and I go okay I don't do the extra
mile which is can you show me where
specifically because that's too much the
transaction is over you pointed where it
is
[Laughter]
so now it's up to me and I'm looking
I see every cheese except for queso
fresco
and I do it for like 12 minutes and I'm
looking and I'm so pissed and a fan
comes by and gives me a very nice
compliment and I they say oh thank you
very much and she walks away and I feel
good but I'm also I'm like I hope I
wasn't a dick I'm really just looking
for this kid so Fresco I don't want her
to think I was in a dick I hope she
comes back and I could be like thank you
again so she knows I'm a nice person and
I don't find it but I do find [ __ ]
cheese that is uh a blend it's like a a
tri-blend of Mexican cheese I'm like
that sounds queso fresco she said the
Mexican thing and then them and then
Fresco's Mexican and so I'm getting the
Mexican tried cheese [ __ ] and I'm
getting it I'm getting a whole bag of it
I get like it's like four pounds I
almost Gotta Throw it over my shoulder
and I get here and she's like and I was
like I didn't get the queso fresco I
want you to understand that this is what
I got and it's Mexican it's fine it's
gonna be fine because I looked up what
you put queso fresco on and it's like I
saw that [ __ ] and when I and and I don't
like that like like white powdery cheese
so I think I actually did a good job
not in the case of Fresco I got the real
[ __ ] that we should have got so it's
fine I did some Ingenuity [ __ ] that's
not the extra mile I did not go the
extra mile but I did some enrichment on
it right
so she's like that's totally fine but
this bag is so big and I'm like what
you're not gonna do is talk about the
good [ __ ] I did like it's a bad thing
too much cheese is also the right amount
of cheese
but she's my angel right and this is a
comedy podcast she didn't complain
but I am now
so I go you're welcome but you got too
much cheese you welcome right so
she's making dinner now and I can't wait
to [ __ ] eat that chicken bowl dude
can't wait to eat that chicken ball dude
she made beef stew the other night man
and she just kind of got on this cooking
kick and I ate that beef stew dude
it was so good and I'm like not even a
beef stew guy
you understand yeah it had rice in it
and rice is my [ __ ] dude
but we put that [ __ ] beef stew on
that rice and just made it and [ __ ]
all oh my god dude I'm just like maybe
I'm a beef stew guy now but I'm not but
it was so good and I say uh nothing like
a home home cooked meal and she's like
yeah you I would cook more uh I just I
forget how much I like it it's just the
setup and the deconstructing part that I
don't like and I was like yeah and
that's why the dishes were in the dish
the sink for a full day and I didn't do
my duties because I didn't want to do it
because sometimes the pots are too big
and I can only fit like one in the
dishwasher and so I got to do like I got
to do it multiple times and it's really
[ __ ] annoying and it's all good
I did my part I did the dishes before I
did the podcast and it's fine but let me
tell you something right now dude
thank you because I was having like a
weird day and I just mean on my insides
I don't even mean outwardly I don't mean
with people I wasn't getting into any
arguments I was just in my head mentally
and I was feeling a bit of anxiety and I
go I literally thought I can't wait till
I do my podcast because I know that
that's gonna fix it and get me
distracted and sure enough baby
sure enough it did and I thank you guys
for that because you're here for me and
you're just as important as as important
as I am for this podcast even though I'm
just saying that because mostly I'm more
important because I'm the one actually
doing the podcast
[Music]
it's loud by Design I made it louder it
might be leveled out when we don't do
one but it was loud in my earphones and
but yeah dude
we love it come see me in Boston
November 12th
um
I uh
I like watching horror movies you know
I like Thrillers the most those are my
favorite type of movies
and you know I go on Apple sometimes I
see the movies I could rent
sometimes I go on Amazon Prime and I see
the [ __ ] bad movies I can watch that
like Eric Roberts were in in 1990 and if
he's got a machine gun I mean dude if I
see a movie
and the cover is Eric Roberts and he's
holding some sort of gun
dude try to get me not to click on that
and sit down for two hours just try
the bigger the gun the quicker The Click
um
so
I'm surfing around with my friend David
Sullivan he's the one who has the Andrew
Jackson here
by the way it gets recognized from the
Vlogs we do on tour report and if you go
to my Chris Lea Channel And subscribe
like And subscribe by the way like And
subscribe here guys uh we're still stuck
at 596 and uh we're trying to you know
there's a conspiracy going on keeping us
keeping us thwarted but
so I'm searching around on the Apple
[ __ ] and I see this movie
and it's called now if you've seen this
movie you know where this is going but
you probably have not seen this movie
okay
it's called speak no evil
I look at the cover it's just like a
a Sunset and there's like shadowy
figures in the distance and I'm like huh
what's this about
so I Google it
let me Google it because I wanna
wait no what not see no evil speak no
evils right speak no evil
um a day and I read a Danish family now
I'm I'm already hooked because those
Danes dude the Danish fit the Danish
people
just already I mean because it's if this
is a thriller
I love it because Danish people you
don't really think about them being okay
so okay but maybe they're extra weird
with the okay
a Danish family visits a Dutch family
and then I go oh okay in this case
two weirds connect
[Music]
okay
lock it throw it away to get out of the
room I gotta call that guy who's talking
about white dudes in jail taking it up
the anus so I am locked in this room
with
the idea of a Danish family going to
visit a Dutch family and I think that
this is a thriller
so I go David found it and he goes what
man he was probably sleeping because
he's always [ __ ] tired or eating
and I read the rest of the synopsis I
say read this a Daniel family visits a
Dutch family they met on a holiday what
was supposed to be now that's where I'm
cemented
if I see the what was supposed to be in
a title I know [ __ ] goes wrong in a
movie
I know I thought one thing and not only
did I think one thing but the people in
the movie thought one thing and I know
something crazy is about to happen but
the people in the movie don't and I'm a
step ahead of the people in the movie
I know some Secrets right so it says
what was supposed to be an idyllic
weekend slowly starts unraveling as the
Danes start uh as the Danes try to stay
and I gotta click on the thing God damn
it
um as the Danes tried to stay polite in
the face of unpleasantness dude
and I'm just like
but a thriller
I go like this
so this movie is about people
Danish people
this is the tagline this is the synopsis
they chose
the Danes try to stay polite
in the face of unpleasantness
they didn't say
during this harrowing Adventure they
didn't say
from
The Duchess
terrifying them
they said they try to stay polite in the
face of unpleasantness now what is
unpleasantness now I'm thinking what are
the things that are unpleasant bad
breath
uh you know
um
nausea
a windows open and it's too cold and you
don't want to get up to close it right
and I'm like
that doesn't sound so great to watch a
movie about
but this is in the Thriller category
so I'm hooked
dude
now you got it Dane
a Dutch
and two Americans
sitting pretty dude from jump
so I turn it on
and when I tell you
now I'm watching a movie this is what
the movie's about and I'm not gonna ruin
this movie for you because
I guess this is in a way me reviewing
this movie and I think this is an
important thing to talk about on the
podcast I know it's not just another
movie review
but
I'm watching the movie
and it starts with this tone of Terror
right and what I mean by that is it's
just showing a guy at a pool
with his wife and another guy shows up
at the resort and says hey our it points
to the chair with the guy's stuff on it
and says can I uh use this chair you're
using it and the guy goes like this uh
uh yeah you know what uh yeah okay and
take this stuff off gives the guy the
chair now he obviously didn't want to do
it but he was being polite and
and that's just something that we all
deal with so I go like this oh I'm in
this movie in a way but the music and
the score is music and score that would
be in a horror movie so I'm like but a
thriller though
guys is asking him for his chair
dude when I and if you're a fan of mine
you know if I see some [ __ ] like this
I'm all in dude right
the movie continues for an hour and a
half
and it's just this kind of [ __ ] that
happens for an hour and 20 minutes
like the girl says she's a vegetarian
and they invite them to hang out with
them later on in the year and they stay
at this cabin with them on holiday and
they're like the first thing they do is
like you got to try this board and she's
like no that's okay and he's like nah
try it try it and you basically like you
know it's a suggestion but he's like
kind of force it he's like okay and she
eats it and and this happened for an
hour and a half these weird things that
are happening with the [ __ ] music
that would be in like
you know
sicario not a horror movie but like
you know
like that [ __ ]
and I look over to David like 40 minutes
in and I say to him and I'm on the edge
of my seat I say to him I was like why
is this
so how is this terrifying nothing is
happening and I'm like scared
and he goes like this
boy I don't know man it's just really
unnerving you know and I was like it is
unnerving he says really unnerving man
and we keep saying it for the next
that's unnerving man really unnerving
I'm like it is unnerving isn't it and I
sit and it's an hour in the movie and I
go like this this movie
I hope it holds up through the end
because this movie
is if this keeps going it's a
masterpiece
and I'm not dude I don't say movies or
songs or [ __ ] or masterpieces I am so
hooked up on this movie and it's so good
and I relate to it so much but also it's
terrifying and they're just chilling I
don't get it
now I'm not ruining this movie
but an hour and 30 minutes into the
movie
something happens in the movie that's a
scene and it is the most and I say this
not lightly
it is the most horrific thing I have
ever seen in cinema
it is so I I dare to say traumatizing
it's so bad for me I'm 42. people get
trauma when they're like four I think it
traumatized me I'm 42. and I go like
this yo David hey David tell me what
happens I'm out for about a minute and a
half and he's watching it he stands up
puts his hanger on his head he goes oh
no man oh no and I say what's happening
and he says exactly what you think's
happening man and I say I actually don't
think it's happening because no movie
would ever have this happening and he
says well it's happening man
and he sits down and I look at his face
before I see the movie and I look and
his face is even whiter than it [ __ ]
is normally and he's from [ __ ] Texas
and I say are you kidding me
I have trauma now
we rode out to the end of the movie and
I did not watch the part that I turned
my head in and at the end also something
at the end to end something really weird
happens too that I had to turn my head
for a little bit but my point is this I
get mad
I get mad at this movie because I'm like
man I was watching this whole thing and
I was into it and I don't want to have
to see this horrific thing I'm a dad now
I can't watch this [ __ ]
and I'm mad and then I realize I'm mad
because what the [ __ ] man these people
who are going through all this weird
[ __ ] that should have just [ __ ] said
something they should have left the
[ __ ] house
but I wasn't you know being like a black
person in the movie theater like no
don't go in there I was keeping it
inside
and if they just said something I
wouldn't [ __ ] have to see that
[ __ ] and I'm just so invested man
and maybe black people have it right
dude because they're saying this [ __ ]
and these people got into this
predicament because they weren't saying
[ __ ] they just let [ __ ] happen and keep
happening and that's why this movie is
this [ __ ] most terrifying movie I've
ever seen because these people didn't
didn't
do what they know they should have done
dude
and for that reason this movie is still
one of the best movies I've ever seen in
my entire life
I will say that one scene is so horrific
that I wish I didn't see the movie
that's how that's how horrific that
scene is
and this is how good the movie is and
[ __ ] man Kristen Taft drop the director
of this movie you are one [ __ ] up dude
and you know it and you know it because
you made two other movies I don't have a
[ __ ] extremely [ __ ] up online
and I watched another one too because of
my OCD I had to watch the next one the
next day
and it's called a horrible woman and
obviously you have so different shares
but I have to watch it because you know
what I [ __ ] love that movie
I need another one parents it's called
parents and these parents go and they're
[ __ ] whatever you [ __ ] look it up
but
that's the scariest thing in life
is not saying and doing the [ __ ] that
you wish you would have done
and that coupled with this Horror made
it I mean this guy the way it unfolds
holy [ __ ] so
I am telling you two things it is
without a doubt and I've sat with this
movie for days already so I know it's
true because usually I don't decide if I
like a movie or not right away I have to
let it sit with me
this is one of without a doubt one of
the greatest movies I've ever seen in my
life and I am also telling you don't
watch it
and now you're gonna [ __ ] watch it
because you know but
don't
and I'm not I don't say this to be cute
you know I've decided now I always I
mean I won't even mention it but it's
just too good
um anyway dude this guy
Kristen taftra
the movies he makes unreal
I can't watch certain things now that I
have a [ __ ]
kid you know
it's tough
saw the movie Horrible woman that he
also did and it's about some woman who
like manipulates a dude and keeps
manipulating him and it's crazy wild man
it's good dude this guy's a great
filmmaker for those two movies I'm gonna
watch his other one next it's called
parents that was the first one he did
um
man
yeah it was a ride bro
uh let's look at this Jeremy fragrance
thing because this guy is just uh I'm
the number one I'm the Champion I'm the
best wow nobody has done what I have
done in my field I'm Jeremy fragrance
the number one fragrance icon I did 1
000 push-ups in one hour on the Fifth
Avenue I'm the number one no I'm the
Champion unreal dude on the Fifth Avenue
wow this guy is
okay I'm the number one I'm the Champion
I'm the best nobody has done what I have
done in my field I'm Jeremy fragrance
the number one fragrance icon I did 1
000 push-ups in one hour on the Fifth
Avenue I'm the number one I'm the
Champion dude 1 000 push-ups in one hour
is that what he said
that's so many
right
oh yeah
guy's pretty ripped but uh
he's still got like a kid face you know
dude I don't like when guys with kid
faces get older like the actors that
were like popping when they were 22 and
[ __ ] and then they get older and you're
like oh that's what you look like now
that's [ __ ] weird right
um but this guy
did it I mean in my field which is his
field is sniffing
his field is sniffing good uh it's a
good uh
perfume
I did a lot I did
I I did a 1000 push-up
I mean the guy does coke right for sure
dude let's watch this again
I'm the number one I'm the Champion I'm
the best nobody has done what I have
done in my field I'm Jeremy fragrance
the number one fragrance icon I did 1
000 push-ups in one hour on the Fifth
Avenue I'm the number one I'm the
Champion
wow dude I'm the I'm the number one I'm
the Champion on the uh uh
I did push-ups on the Fifth Avenue dude
hey man drop the that's so far and
that's what makes you the most foreign
the guy's just
how about how uh takeoff was murdered
man
so sad rest in peace to take off dude
those rappers were like you know it's
it's so weird that these [ __ ] what's
weird is rappers keep dying and
comedians keep dying and comedians maybe
for their unhealthy living make sense
like if they're eating too much or
drinking too much you know but Like
Rappers keep dying because they get shot
which I guess you know they live the
game too hard but this guy didn't even
do that the thing about takeoff which is
he's from uh
um
Migos uh it's like he doesn't uh uh they
were just like a party rap you know they
would rap about some of the same [ __ ]
that these other guys were rap about but
like they were just like
party guys and I feel like they were
good guys I don't know maybe the one of
them isn't a good guy but not this one
this one was like takeoff was like
just some dude that was like
and he got shot at a dice game and he
wasn't even doing the dice game dude
imagine you're at a dice game not even
doing the dice game and that's the last
[ __ ] experience you have
28 years old and his brother is in the
group his brother's name is cuevo he's
cuevo from the group and I just [ __ ]
my heart goes out to him man
these rappers like [ __ ] uh
well the other guys died just sitting
Idol too right um
the uh the um
the other one that everyone a lot of
people pretended to like after he died
not that they pretended to like but they
were like bout it that they were about
it
nipsy hustle really good but like
everyone celebrated him hardcore after
he died and it's like we get it you knew
him first you know what I mean guy was a
good rapper but he was just kind of
chilling too not to say you know I think
a lot of these guys because I think he
was like a reformed gangster I think was
the thing with him
you think so yeah and I'm not sure but
uh just like [ __ ] man
don't be uh
rappers and Comedians and firemen man
those guys
rappers comedians firemen and just kind
of General people the general populace
in Colombia they don't have high
expectation uh
uh
life expectancy
let's do some deserved scales and some
uh tinders
Tinder uh
things what could go wrong playing
football with cars oh no
[Music]
I mean what
[Music]
I mean Sun eventful just immediate one
what an idiot
I mean just the people in the car just
get out of the car
I mean I mean who would have thought
cars driving towards each other
very quickly
in a straight line
that's an accident that's going to
happen
well it's not even an accident it's what
you're meant to do look at these look
they're driving did they even slow down
at all oh [ __ ] I mean you can die from
that what's the goal
thank you
what is this uh football with cars is
that like a thing
football with cars I'm gonna google it
because this is crazy deserve it scale I
mean that's not even funny that's sad
deserve at scale I'm gonna okay that's
the service scale but I'm gonna look up
football with cars though
rocket soccer Derby oh that's a video
game right
got it car football here's another one
Volkswagen
the thing that's different about the
verb no why am I not signed in
I'm pissed
here we go this is the gauntlet thrower
in question it's cool
here we go
Jesus
don't be doing that
I'm gonna put this under the deserver
scale thing so you know the link
um Jesus
that's [ __ ] up
okay here's another what could go wrong
what could go wrong hanging onto a
bridge wow
look at the back of this chick is the
chick that would do this
hell yeah dude
she's not gonna be able to hold on to
that
you fall down why is she doing that
dude [ __ ] yeah if I was walking above
the bridge I go like this
oh my God oh my God oh my god wow so
good idiot idiots deserve at scale eight
the first thing is luckily she didn't
injured her legs injured
um it's foreign
dude
I'm if I [ __ ] if do if my friend did
that oh dude no I would not stop and I
would be laughing the whole way the rest
of the time
that is so lovely
that that happened
I would love it
um I can't believe these people I guess
I would I don't know anything like this
when you leave your bike on the road to
join a fight oh no dude
so there's a fight guy gets off the bike
oh did a jump kick
the kid jumped off the bike and [ __ ]
started pouncing on the other guy and
then the car ran over the bike dude
deserve it is good that's a high one
that's 10.
there we go let's get in of course they
have soccer jerseys on because it's a
Farm Place
oh wow he's helping his friend I like
that wow dude that's great had no idea
that was
that was coming
I wonder if that was a real fight or not
I wish I hope it was why I don't want
people fighting but
makes it funny if it was I thought he
was being a hero lost his bike what
could go wrong shooting at an aerosol
can oh get out of here dude
it was at this moment that he knew he
[ __ ] up
oh dude there's so many people in that
room
did that just did that just is that is
that how they make people
before hey it was at this moment because
he knew he [ __ ] up look the people
that's how you make people two people
were made wow
two people were made they came from
Arizona where you come from we come from
Sacramento where you come from aerosol
aerosol in a bullet
bully I told that story in here before
right
when I was in New York and I would go to
this place called Silver Bullet and the
guy would always [ __ ] pick up and go
still available yeah he's not I mean
Ivan is not an Emmy he knows
here we go while showing what could go
wrong about showing off here we go oh
these are the best the showing off ones
are the best oh in car
look at these idiots
poor other guy dude just [ __ ] what a
[ __ ]
who's videoing you know
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
idiots dude
like don't be uh I don't I don't
understand this [ __ ] man I was never
that I never I never want to drive
fasting cars I know and I have fast cars
I have a fast car
and I don't care I've gone over a
hundred one time dude once and it was
barely over a hundred I don't care yes I
know I live in LA and I don't take the I
don't go fast like that but like why
dude
I just don't do it man
I like a nice engine I like the way a
car looks but like I'm not trying to get
[ __ ] real fast the potholes alone but
I just I don't do it
I don't understand people go so [ __ ]
fast man it's not fun especially ever
being in a car
someone else is driving fast dude I
can't do that I want to [ __ ] myself I'm
I have the lack of control now I'm not
even the best driver don't tell my wife
because I am but like she always says
I'm not a good driver and I always
disagree there but I'm not the best
driver but like dude I do the [ __ ]
if I'm not in control of it um I I dude
I'm too scared one time I had a buddy um
that was uh
we ate food and then he wanted to go to
Jack In The Box and he was just a menace
right and he was like let's go to Jack
In The Box got Jack in the Box bought
Jack in the Box started eating Jack in
the Box as he was driving me home and he
says he's on the freeway and he was so
crazy he was like I'm not going to take
the wheel you better take the wheel I'm
Gonna Take the Wheel no matter what and
I was like come on man he's like you
take the wheel I'll just let it swerve
it'll hit the wall for all I don't care
and I was like [ __ ] man come on dude and
I didn't grab the wheel and he grabbed
it at the last second and we swerved and
we're in the freeway and then I was like
man that guy's crazy I was like I think
that might have to be the last time I
hang out with that guy because he was so
like doing [ __ ] like that and [ __ ]
and in like a year he ended up
committing you know I don't want to say
it because
it's sad and I want to trigger people
but he ended up like you know ending his
life and that sucks dude
uh uh well that was sad I didn't mean to
be so sad but like yeah I don't like
going fasting cars maybe it's from that
but even before that I didn't like it
but now definitely don't
Brea Improv I'll be there uh New Year's
Eve Boston I'll be there a very soon
um November 12th
Boston Massachusetts we added a show uh
Lakeland Florida Jacksonville Florida uh
San Diego California Seattle San Antonio
Portland these are the ones that are
coming up so go to chrysalia.com get
your tickets okay that's the end of the
episode for YouTube if you want to catch
the raw uncut unedited version go on
over to our patreon patreon.com
crystallia and we have about 18 episodes
also that are on our patreon that are
not available to the public so you can
go and get those right now for only six
dollars just go to Chris don't go to
patreon.com
crystalia and we also do segments called
review mode and we have a bunch of stuff
over there so go check it out did a
podcast with Kristen uh thanks very much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]